there's a study that's going on that's
been going on since 1938 longest study
ever it's called Harvard study of adult
development and basically their aim was
to find out like what creates a healthy
happy life and so they looked at the
lives of different metrics over 700 men
their thousands and then their children
and it's a longitudinal study which
means it's like being studied over time
basically what they found is that one of
the biggest indicators of predictors of
health is actually not exercise it's not
whether you smoke too much or drink too
much or don't do those things it's
actually the quality of your
relationships and so even when they
account for smoking alcohol drug testing
it's still demonstrating that
relationships have the most profound
effect on us and and I'm saying they
have physiological implications not just
psychological or at least so they know
that relationships have some kind of
isolated effect on our experiences